il ya 60 ans naissait un journal
satirique hara kiri le magazine bête et
méchant créé par françois cavanna et
georges bernier plus connu sous le nom
de professeur choron comme la chercher à
caractériser le rire à gorge déployée en
vente dès septembre 1960 le mensuel
connaît rapidement le succès et l'équipe
de hara kiri
mais très vite un pied dans la télé
grâce à l'émission de variétés les
raisins verts prenez votre récepteur
houle enfoncé sur la tête de votre femme
ça fume bien on enlève ceux qui comme
nous ont transformé leurs vieilles
femmes en catherine langeais nous
écrivent ils ont gagné 1969
en plus du mensuel un hebdo et créer
novembre 1970 le journal titre bal
tragique à colombey un mort en référence
au décès du général de gaulle hara kiri
hebdo est censuré dans la foulée
interdiction d'exposition dans les
kiosques
l'interdiction de vente aux mineurs
quinze ans après françois cavanna
revenait sur cette couverture
huit jours avant savoir s'était produit
un accident très grave
baldé pris feu dans une campagne 820 sa
mort la prennent la semaine d'après de
roulement de loi demeure on cherche sur
la couverture secte à qui l'elysée
lebron bal tragique à colombey un mort
on savait que c'était dangereux
c'est tellement beau qu'on voit pas ce
qu est un autre magazine le remplace
charlie hebdo
de son côté le mensuel continue de
paraître des artistes participent au
contenu coluche marcel amont ou thierry
le luron lors de tournages de roman
photo
sans oublier les femmes nues sur auxonne
fasse un effort a l'effet particulier
mais moi je trouve que c'est passé c'est
joli je sais que les lecteurs aiment
bien et puis
il faut qu'ils aient des filles à poil
dans un showroom mais moi tu vois voilà
c'est ça qui me gêne un peu mince il
faut creed en 1979
al'approche de ses 20 ans un journaliste
demande à françois cavanna et au
dessinateur gb sierra qui rit sera
encore là d'ici dix ans à l'espoir qu'on
pourrait avoir ses dires les plus besoin
bien sûr que ça soit magnifique
harmonieux et que tout le monde soit
tolérant et que les libertés soit elle
qu'on ait plus besoin de ce bail à
chaque semaine ou chaque mois pour pour
les propos pour les chambres mais les
ventes baissent 1989
le journal est en faillite il y aura
plusieurs tentatives de relance sans
succès en 2000 nouvel essai nouvelle
équipe
à l'intérieur du magazine les astuces
pour ne pas payer ses impôts le parking
aux scolaires ou luce est resté fidèle à
l'esprit est pas à la lettre
parce qu'on fait à l'arrêt creed en 2002
ne sera rien à voir avec leur acquérir
les 60
c'est un échec seulement quatre numéros
parus c'est la disparition définitive de
hara kiri
[Musique]